there are the beginnings of an
intellectual revulsion at what
conservative what has been done to
conservatism as a governing philosophy
in America and I think one of the roles
the day the dish is now trying to play
is to be a place where those voices can
be can be brought to a wider audience so
I think a Bruce Bartlett who along with
me in the early part of the Bush
administration called them out on their
fiscal irresponsibility is a voice that
I'm very happy to to to keep bringing I
think much later someone like David
Fromm has come to that recognition even
though I think we're still gonna
disagree about foreign policy I think
there are some libertarian voices that
are out there and I think a younger
generation of reasoned people I think of
I think of people like Damon linka there
are there are people out there
unfortunately what's happened in
Washington and more generally is that
the conservative movement is bankrolled
by certain large donors and with certain
overwhelming interests and they police
the discourse with a ferocity and a
lockstep mentality that has frozen
conservatism as a as a as a philosophy
in place and turned it into an ideology
that cannot ever change or Elijah it
with such fundamentalist concepts that
there can be no real conservative
dialogue because dialogue is not what
fundamentalism is about and the price of
limply existing as a conservative in
Washington to be in good standing is to
obey the dictates of whichever this
constellation of donors and
organizations from heritage to AEI
to even some like pajamas media which is
apparently financed by people are also
financing West Bank settlements
is if you stray you are expelled and
then also thoroughly demonized so
intellectually we are you know the
blogosphere allows these kind of ideas
to percolate and
I mean Connor Freitas door for example
is a young conservative whom I've
brought on specifically with the mandate
of because find encourage let us bring
to light young writers right-of-center
who are not yet have not been yet
basically bought by this establishment
and then coerced to certain positions
Daniel Harrison is another person now
these people don't normal agree by him
means that's the point
I mean but they do not they they have
acknowledged that conservatism in the
past 10 15 20 years it's not that there
was a great period of pure great
conservatism which never had this some
of these populist xenophobic racist
bigoted strains it's that that was
always there it is that there was also a
lot of good stuff there that were
responding to contingent situations such
as the collapse of the social democracy
model in 1970s and a really smart
critique of the welfare state and really
I think critical insight into how one
defeats solving communism what what's
happened is that all that stuff has
slowly been marginalized well the worst
has come to the surface and that that
won't change overnight and I think from
everything we're seeing talk radio and
these I think essentially corrupting
institutions in Washington are turning
conservatism into something they're
really very creepy but also emotionally
and psychically powerful for people so
what you do is all you can do is is
write books write articles write blogs
that articulate what you believe